the jurogan experience duncan thinks
that the biden that fell off the bike
yesterday was a fake man dude no you
think it's a body double did you see his
[ __ ] body pull it up
he's got a nice bob yeah biden has nice
legs he doesn't hate i think you're
hating
i was i couldn't have been happier to
watch that guy fall off that [ __ ]
body that's how high gas prices are i'll
be honest he is the gift that keeps
giving if you're not a biden fan i
haven't seen it yet let's see it it's
fun all right wait you haven't
holy [ __ ] i think that's him dude watch
the video yeah it's definitely because
the video of him falling oh he looks
pretty toned it's so sad he says i'm
good wait he's already wearing he's not
wearing knee pads
i think above it is the video that's it
it's so sad should have a knee pad i
hope it's just he didn't have any nip no
he goes down hard can i see what's the
wobble style
no no wobble dude he's got good legs
that's why i'm kind of amazed that he
falls down so much because if you look
at his
legs they look pretty sturdy
so he gets there and oh that'll [ __ ] you
up no we didn't see it
fake oh
thank god he couldn't stop he was
married every time he felt that many
people would help you no no there's
plenty of other other videos look at
that guy smiling because he got it that
guy was so happy
you see the excitement in his thumbs
yeah he's gonna give me no matter what
you see somebody fall off a bike you're
happy yeah yeah you're happy but when
they're that old it becomes really funny
like if a 20 year old guy falls like
that it's not as funny as a 79 year old
guy falling like that yeah the president
the president coming to be like hey
everybody who is who falls more than him
because he used to be they used to joke
around about gerald ford being clown
that's right that was the last guy that
they talked about being a klutz yeah i
mean that's right he fell a lot that was
a good thing yeah he would fall walking
up the air force one stairs that's great
no you didn't know that yeah well here
he goes there you go stupid ass there he
goes he's down oh my god he was stopped
what was that well his foot got stuck in
the little [ __ ] pedal thing and he
thought he was going to pull he was
going to lean his weight on his right
leg but he had already put his
try to get his foot out of the pedal
thing and he already committed to going
down there he goes i'm fine you shook it
up
he got up well too that's a hard fall i
think he's talking to a youngin he's all
right he does love the youngest he does
love he'll just smell them
bob's dead shut up
it's funny before it was like did he get
assassinated no no it's biden he just
took a spill
yeah biden it's such a it'd be so funny
to be like the pr people on that and be
like we're gonna get you you're gonna be
riding a bike everybody's saying you're
not spry right here we go
you